hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to slender anxiety look at
this I'm in my old recording room I bet
I'm waking up my brother over there but
he's right over across this room oh it's
so weird being back I just did a few
videos right before I moved to LA but
other than that it's been very long
since I was last year and my hair is a
hopeless mess I'm sorry I just woke up
not a few minutes ago
last night was Bob's wedding and
obviously my birthday I was up very late
seeing old friends and family and of
course Bob's wedding which was awesome I
am so happy for Bob I even got a little
teary eyed myself and I didn't have
anything for today and as you guys know
I've never missed days upload ever ever
ever in my life and I didn't know that I
wouldn't have enough time to do as many
recordings as I thought I was hoping to
do a little more with Wade obviously Bob
had no time cuz he was busy with a
wedding and this set up is all
duct-taped together as case in point
I am play I'm recording this on a shoe
on a box for a web cam that I'm not even
using I don't even know how I'm gonna
get by but either way that was a long
introduction that you guys probably
didn't need to know but thank you for
all the birthday wishes and everything
that you've given me and it was but it
had been a while since um since I played
a slender game and this one is called
slender anxiety and it seemed like it
had a lot of potential because I think
it's as you can tell by the recording
thing there with all the the camera
notifications and the graphical quality
of it it's based on the slender the
slender the arrivals end in which I'm
not sure I didn't think that it was on
or I couldn't remember what engine it
was on and I've got a little problem
because I mouse is going outside I just
got to remember not to click but man
it's weird being back I I just love
being back in Cincinnati I love the
weather better here even though it was
like hot and muggy when I got here but
it was just like mmm that's home to me I
remember how hot and deliciously moist
the air is I'm sorry for everyone who
doesn't like the word moist but now man
just being back home is really great I
mean la gives a lot of opportunities I
wouldn't have met nearly as many YouTube
and I'm gonna be out there for a while
at least a few years but still being
back home it makes me miss the things
that I have not seen in a while
obviously my family and friends and and
seeing Bob back here and being so happy
at the wedding god it was just such a
beautiful beautiful time I mean it did
rain just a little bit but after we were
already out of the reception what is
that I thought that was tentacles over
there never mind anyway this is anyway
back to the game I've been talking about
what's going on before but you know
Burton yesterday was my birthday and the
wedding but all the birthday stuff is
going on today why is there a crash
fighter jet here is there a page on the
fighter jet the last will and testament
of whatever poor bastard flew into this
onto the abode of a forest can I climb
up there
I do not new hello no I can't but I can
zoom in on it that's really useful I'm
glad I can do that but I cannot climb up
there can I climb on you now this game
did have a lot of high ratings and
obviously it looks fairly nice given
that it was using some of the same
assets and obviously the same engine as
the main Sun dream I don't know if it
got permission for that sort of stuff I
want to assume I want to give it the
benefit of the doubt that it is but I
have heard that this game does have
quite a few bugs in it so we're just
gonna go into this with an open mind and
understanding that I didn't have a lot
of time to vet this game and I didn't
have a lot of time to trial this is
literally all I've got I woke up this is
the only time I've got because I got to
get out of the door in about 20 minutes
here so I'm gonna hope to edit this and
get it uploading on the way out and what
is going on with my camera it's going a
little wibbly-wobbly obviously I can't
run forever and I've found a camp where
I'm sure many many Boy Scouts died at
the hand of Slenderman or got turned
into his proxies and I'm gonna find
their mutilated camp counselor corpse
later anybody anybody here bullies look
awfully nice kind of a little bit I
think
is there any point to this I don't know
where I'm supposed to find a page
everything is gonna be lost I am not
used to this area and I don't have
enough time to get used to it because I
just started playing I'm hoping you guys
forgive me if I'm bad at this particular
slender game god it has been so long
since I played this actual slender game
all I know is that I need to follow the
path most of the time oh my god I'm
gonna be lost everybody's gonna be so
mad at me what does that ah nothing I
keep thinking I see things in the forest
but it's actually just like little
details and doodads oh that looks nice
is that a place full of mannequins what
the hell is this Greek architecture
doing in the middle of the woods why is
this here it belongs in a museum
maybe I don't know what that is hello
hello baby hello lady I do not know what
is going on there and I do not want to
know do you have a page why do you look
like you have dicks improve sorry sorry
I didn't mean to do whatever the hell I
just did uh okay I'm just gonna keep on
wandering because I cannot find a single
page I swear oh page hey Trey Pete speak
of the devil
well now I know that I didn't miss any
because it would have gone ding dong
when I saw oh the old slender noise I'm
sorry everybody I'm getting far too
excited about this but oh
okay bye-bye I'm gonna go back to the
Greek architecture go back to the dick
statue so you can't get me everyone
knows that slender is afraid of dick
statues so just everyone who wants to
keep slender away just put dick statues
all over your room at all times don't
answer any question from your parents
your friends your wives your girlfriends
your boyfriend's don't answer anything
just have dick statues everywhere and
you will be safe from the Slender Man
just so you know that's professional
advice from markiplier professional a
hey hi there buddy I do it friend
you're good no no no no no no no no not
yet not yet yet not yet I just started
playing Jesus this guy is very
persistent I only got one page why you
gotta be such a douche er Oh was it only
Jimmy Jabby because I was sprinting that
better not have been the case because
that would be fair hey I saw liar okay
okay it's okay it's okay man I just got
one page how the hell am I supposed to
get all weighed this letter game my back
should be very hard is way too hard with
all the dicks tattoos mm-hmm okay
so what I gotta do is not sprint because
sprinting is what's killing me is that a
slender face over there no I was just a
star in the distance the Northern Star
to guide me towards my pages are my
ultimate destruction is that another
road there oh I thought I was just
wandering into the woods nowhere good
thing there are roads everywhere to
guide me along I honestly don't know
that how I'm gonna be able to get all
eight pages I mean it is a bit cliched
at this point to have like an eight-page
collecting game but I guess you know it
has an excuse because
no no no no
ah come on
that's pathetic I don't have a lot of
time here okay I literally have time for
one more go and then I get a guy got to
get out of here because my I'm meeting
my stepmom for a lunch and then I'm
meeting my mom for my mom's I gotta get
back here my mom birth birthday stuff
you know all that obligation to family
that I that I choose to ignore when I'm
recording these games so I don't know
what I did wrong there but I only got
one page there Slendy bad
maybe you should tone it back just a
little bit it has been so long since I
played this Thunder game I'm actually
gonna go in the woods this time because
I think that there are some other
landmarks obviously I was having trouble
finding pages there I don't know what
the hell I was doing wrong but I was not
finding pages at those landmarks I was
that tell my hope is that I'm gonna be
able to go this way too big and then
find a page somewhere along the line
what is that over there I see something
oh that's just the edge of the woods huh
I can't feel the textures of the trees I
can't feel the environment in my butt I
can't feel anything
I'm totally immune but that was all God
I've reached the invisible wall this is
just a demo by the way in early alpha an
early release whatever you want to call
this is very early in development for
this game I honestly don't know how long
it's been in development for ah here we
go these are exact landmark and made at
the beach mmm some poor news reporter
with the windshield of a news van on the
wind you I heard that give me your page
maybe you what's going on with that that
doesn't make any sense what is that that
doesn't make any sense you textures are
all bunkered up okay so anyway I gotta
find a page somewhere give me all page
there's a policeman here oh come on do
these landmarks not have pages or maybe
it's like maybe it's done up differently
so that the first page is all
is in like one place and then none of
the other pages show up before that I
brought I know I'm probably popping the
microphone a lot with my plosive Peas
I've people anybody who knows to do with
audio knows that but I don't have any
other garden I'm very close to the
microphone because I don't want to be
too loud because I will wake in my
family and nothing is more important
than my family is there nothing you
would not do Captain Kirk
for your family I love his voice there
you know I hadn't really seen Benedict
Cumberbatch before that and I thought
that was actually his voice in that
movie I was very disappointed to hear
that it was edited heavily to give a
more resonant bass a more epicness to a
voice of God I am reaching these
landmarks I'm just not seeing any pages
and I know that it's gonna ding dong
when I find it because it did before
that's why I'm thinking ooh where huh
there ding dong so there are pages here
they're just hard to find give me thank
you now slender is gonna be an immediate
douche and immediately gonna kill me so
long as he doesn't block my path to
getting to the next landmark you son of
a [ __ ] you shut up a [ __ ] I don't have
time to go back again god damn it you're
gonna really put me in the disadvantage
of only having one one page only one
page that's what you're gonna give me
you son of a [ __ ] are a son of a [ __ ]
so either way I guess that's it huh you
guys can find this game it's totally
free there's a link in the description
the game Joel where the download pages I
don't know how to beat this I didn't
have enough time to figure it out so
either way that is slender anxiety and
that's literally all the time I have a
bunch of birthday stuff but I haven't
been ignoring all the stuff I've been
quietly browsing tumblr whenever I had a
chance yesterday and the deviantART page
and I saw all the fan art that you guys
have been giving me for my birthday
thank you guys so much for everything um
I know I haven't a chance to look
closely so there's probably stuff that I
missed and I apologize it's just that I
have been busy with just doing the sort
of stuff so I will get to it if I can't
do today then I will get to it when I go
back home tomorrow I fly out tomorrow
morning so thank you guys so much for
watching please understand that I really
really wanted to be able to show you
guys more I wanted to have a little bit
of a better quality video here but you
hey you got my advice to put dicks
around your room so that's something
there so to get on that low go down to
your local dick statue store and fill up
your rooms with dicks so thank you all
so much for watching hope you have a
great day today I know I'm gonna have a
great birthday celebration with my
family so thanks again everybody for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next video bye bye
open that key I picked up earlier okay
oh this is good so this is where all the
pages came from